>>> TONIGHT, PROTESTER INSIDE
CHINA SPEAKI EXCLUSIVELY TO
CNN.
THIS PROTESTER IS ONE OF
THOUSANDS ACROSS CHINA WHO HAS
TAKEN PART THIS THE WIDESPREAD
DEMONSTRATIONS AGAINST STRICT
ZERO COVID POLICIES LIKE THE ONE
ON YOUR SCREEN WHICH IS IN
SHANGHAI, WHERE PROTESTERS
CLASHED WITH POLICE IN WHITE
HAZMAT SUITS.
NOW THIS PROTESTER SPOKE TO OUR
SELENA WANG, WOULD ONLY SPEAK TO
HER IN A CAR WHILE DISGUISED.
>> THE PROTESTS THAT HAPPENED
WASN'T JUST RANDOM, BECAUSE
THERE WAS THIS SOCIAL ANGER THAT
WAS ACCUMULATING IN EVERYONE,
ESPECIALLY THE MIDDLE CLASS.
SO I THINK THE PURPOSE OF THIS
POLICY HAS SHIFTED.
IT SHIFTED FROM ACTUALLY
PROTECTING PEOPLE'S LIVES TO A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN THEY NEVER
TOLD US ABOUT THE DATA, THE
EXACT DATA.
HOW MANY PEOPLE DIED OF THE
COVID AND HOW MANY PEOPLE DIED
AS OF COLLATERAL DAMAGE AS OF
ZERO COVID POLICY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU'RE GOING SEE MUCH MORE FROM
THIS INCREDIBLE INTERVIEW THAT
SELE
SELENA CONDUCTED.
SHAKE XI SHAKING HANDS WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE EUROPEAN
COUNCIL.
THE GOVERNMENT CLAIMS IT WILL
RELAX SOME COVID RESTRICTIONS
EVER SO SLIGHTLY, LIKE LETTING
PEOPLE WITH COVID QUARANTINE IN
THEIR OWN HOMES INSTEAD OF THE
MASS FACILITIES THAT YOU'VE SEEN
THE HORRIBLE IMAGES OF, SOME OF
THE HORRIBLE CONDITIONS LIKE A
PUBLIC BATHROOM WHERE SOME WERE
FORCED TO QUARANTINE SLEEPING ON
A FLOOR, OR WHERE HUNDREDS IF
NOT THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN PACKED
INTO THESE VAST QUARANTINE
CENTERS.
SELINA WANG IS "OUTFRONT" IN
BEIJING.
THIS INTERVIEW YOU DID WITH THE
PROTESTER IS VERY SIGNIFICANT.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US?
>> YEAH, ERIN, I MEAN, IT IS SO
HARD TO GET ANY PERSON IN CHINA
TO SPEAK ON CAMERA TO MEDIA, LET
ALONE ON SUCH A SENSITIVE TOPIC.
BUT THIS PERSON FELT PASSIONATE
THAT SHARING WITH THE WORLD,
WHILE THE PROTESTERS MAKE UP A
TINY PORTION OF CHINA'S
POPULATION, THEY REALLY SEE
THEMSELVES AS SPEAKING FOR THE
MASSES, BECAUSE ZERO COVID HAS
BEEN A UNIFYING SOURCE OF ANGER
FOR PEOPLE, YOUNG, OLD, RICH OR
POOR.
AND THIS PERSON DESCRIBED BEING
A PART OF THE DEMONSTRATION IN
BEIJING AS BOTH SCARY BUT ALSO
EMPOWERING.
>> WILL NOT PROTECT YOU.
>> THIS PERSON ONE OF THOUSANDS
OF ACROSS CHINA WILLING TO PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO SPEAK
OUT.
YEARS OF PENT-UP ANGER OVER
CHINA'S DRACONIAN COVID
LOCKDOWNS BOILING OVER INTO
PROTESTS.
>> I FELT LIKE I LOST CONTROL OF
MY LIFE BECAUSE OF THIS COVID
POLICY.
NOBODY IS TELLING YOU WHEN THIS
IS GOING TO END.
WE ARE LIMITED PHYSICALLY, AND
NOW WE'RE LIMITED MENTALLY.
WE ARE FORBIDDEN TO EXPRESS OUR
IDEAS.
>> Reporter: FOR SOME, THAT
CATHARTIC EMOTIONAL RELEASE
SPILLED INTO CALLS FOR POLITICAL
CHANGES.
SOME EVEN CHANTED FOR XI JINPING
TO STEP DOWN.
>> HE IS THE ONE WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS WHOLE
POLICY THING.
BUT FOR ME, FIRST THING FIRST, I
WANT A ZERO COVID POLICY GONE.
AND IF WE HAVE MORE FREEDOM
SPEECH AND FREEDOM OF PRESS, OF
COURSE THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU GUYS
ACHIEVED BY PARTICIPATING IN
THAT PROTEST?
>> IF YOU DON'T DEMONSTRATE, IF
YOU DON'T SHOW THEM YOUR CHOICE,
YOUR ID, THEY WILL NEVER KNOW.
>> Reporter: AND THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENED NEXT.
CHINA'S SECURITY APPARATUS
SWIFTLY SMOTHERED THE PROTESTS.
CNN IS SHIELDING THE PROTESTER'S
IDENTITY BECAUSE OF FEARS OF
RETRIBUTION.
EVEN CONDUCTING THE INTERVIEW IN
A CAR TO AVOID TRACKING FROM
AUTHORITIES.
POLICE ARE CALLING AND VISITING
THE HOMES OF SOME PROTESTERS.
AND IN SHANGHAI, RANDOMLY
STOPPING PEOPLE TO CHECK THEIR
PHONES ON STREETS AND WHAT
APPEARS TO BE IN SUBWAYS.
PROTESTERS SAY THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR VPNs NEEDED TO USE BAND APPS
LIKE TWITTER OR TELEGRAM, WHICH
SOME PROTESTERS USE TO
COMMUNICATE.
ANOTHER PROTESTER TOLD CNN "I'M
AFRAID WE CANNOT HOLD PROTESTS
LIKE THIS AGAIN IN THE FUTURE.
THERE ARE ALWAYS UNDERCOVER
AGENTS IN OUR TELEGRAM GROUP.
EVERY FEW METERS ON THE STREET
THERE ARE POLICE AND POLICE
DOGS.
THE WHOLE ATMOSPHERE IS
CHILLING.
I'M IN THE CENTER OF A PROTEST
IN BEIJING RIGHT NOW.
THEY'RE CHANTING THAT THEY DON'T
WANT COVID TESTS.
THEY WANT FREEDOM.
LESS THAN 24 HOURS AFTER THIS,
WE DROVE BACK TO THAT SPOT.
POLICE CARS AS FAR AS THE EYE
COULD SEE.
THEN A FEW DAYS LATER -- IT'S
PRETTY MUCH BACK TO NORMAL, LIKE
NOTHING EVER HAPPENED.
AND THAT IS PRECISELY THE GOAL
OF THE COMMUNIST PARTY.
CNN HAS VERIFIED PROTESTS
ERUPTED IN AT LEAST 17 CHINESE
CITIES, BUT EVERY SINGLE ONE HAS
BEEN STAMPED OUT.
IN GUANGZHOU, RESIDENTS
DESTROYED COVID TESTING BOOTHS.
POLICE IN RIOT GEAR IMMEDIATELY
SWARM IN.
THEY MARCH THROUGH A MARKET
SHOUTING AT PEOPLE TO LEAVE,
FIRING TEAR GAS TO DISPERSE
PROTESTERS, PUSHING THROUGH WITH
CHEELDS AND MAKING ARRESTS.
AUTHORITIES HAVE GONE INTO
OVERDRIVE TO SENSOR ALL EVIDENCE
OF UNREST ONLINE.
>> THE WHITE SHEET OF PAPER
REPRESENTS THE CENSORSHIP AND
CANNOT ARREST US FOR JUST
HOLDING A WHITE PAPER.
I STILL HAVE THAT WHITE PAPER I
PROTESTED.
I PUT IT IN MY DIARY AS A
SOUVENIR TO SHOW MY FUTURE
GENERATIONS THAT YOU SHOULD
ALWAYS FIGHT FOR YOUR RIGHTS,
AND NEVER LET YOUR VOICE BE
SILENCED.
>> Reporter: HOW DOES IT MAKE
YOU FEEL, THOUGH, THAT THE
GOVERNMENT EVEN CENSORED
PICTURES.
>> BY DOING THIS THEY'RE GOING
TO MAKE THE CROWD ANGRIER.
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO SILENCE US,
THEY SHOULD REALLY FOCUS AND TRY
TO THINK WHY THIS HAPPENED.
>> Reporter: AUTHORITIES ARE
SILENCING THEM, BUT IT SEEMS
THEY ARE LISTENING.
RIGHT AFTER THE RIOTS IN
GUANGZHOU, THE CITY STARTED
LIFTING SOME LOCKDOWNS, REMOVING
COVID ROADBLOCKS.
>> UNSEALED, WE ARE UNSEALED!
A MAN SCREAMS WITH EXCITE AS HE
BIKES THROUGH STREETS OPENED UP.
BUT SO MANY OTHERS ARE STILL
COUNTING DOWN THEIR DAYS IN
QUARANTINE IN LOCKDOWN,
WONDERING WHEN ZERO COVID WILL
REALLY END.
A LOT OF THE PROTESTERS LIKE THE
PERSON I INTERVIEWED, THEY ARE
YOUNG, IN THEIR 20s AND 30s, BUT
THEY WERE STILLBORN BEFORE
FACEBOOK, GOOGLE AND YOUTUBE
WERE BANNED IN CHINA.
SO THE PERSON MADE THE POINT TO
ME THAT DESPITE THE PATRIOTIC
EDUCATION THEY'VE BEEN GETTING
FED IN SCHOOL, THEY STILL
REMEMBER WHAT A MORE OPEN CHINA
LOOKED LIKE.
NOW MOST REALIZE IT IS TOO
DANGEROUS AND UNREALISTIC TO
CALL FOR XI JINPING TO STEP
DOWN, BUT AT THE VERY LEAST,
THEY JUST WANT THEIR OLD LIVE
BACK WHEN THEIR LIVES WEREN'T
CONTROLLED BY LOCKDOWNS, TESTING
AND LIVE QUARANTINES.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THAT
INCREDIBLE, COURAGEOUS REPORTING
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO DO AND THAT
INTERVIEW FROM BEIJING.
I WANT TO GO NOW TO DESMOND
SCHUMM, A POWERFUL CHINESE
BUSINESSMAN WHOSE EX-WIFE WENT
MISSING IN CHINA IN 2017.
HE IS ALSO THE AUTHOR OF "RED
ROULETTE: A STORY OF WEALTH,
POWER AND VENGEANCE IN TODAY'S
CHINA."
I HOPE YOU WILL READ IT.
I FOUND IT INCREDIBLY POWERFUL.
DESMOND, YOU JUST SAW SELINA,
SHE SHIELDED THE IDENTITY OF THE
PROTESTER SHE SPOKE WITH.
BUT CHINESE OFFICIALS ARE USING
A LOT OF METHODS TO FIND THESE
PROTESTERS TO TRACK THEM DOWN.
HOW CONCERNED WOULD YOU BE IF
YOU WERE A PROTESTER?
>> I THINK THE RISK IS
TREMENDOUS.
I MEAN, THERE ARE REPORTS THAT
CHINESE HAS DONE THIS FACIAL
RECOGNITION EVEN WITH YOUR MASK
ON.
SO I THINK THE GOVERNMENT IS --
THE CRACKDOWN IS ALREADY
HAPPENING.
AND I THINK GIVEN THE RECORD FOR
THE PAST DECADE, XI JINPING'S
CRACKDOWN WILL BE SEVERE AND
BRUTAL.
>> AND LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THAT.
WHEN YOU SAY "SEVERE AND
BRUTAL," WHAT DO YOU THINK XI
WILL DO TO THE PROTESTERS?
>> THEIR STANDARD MODE OF
OPERATION LIKE WHAT HAPPENED TO
MY EX-WIFE IS DISAPPEAR.
BY THE GENTLEMAN WHO HAD THE
BANNER ON A BEIJING BRIDGE A
MONTH AGO, HE HAS DISAPPEARED
AND HASN'T BEEN HEARD IN THE
LAST MONTHS.
SO I THINK THE LEADERS OF THE
PROTEST MOVEMENT COULD POSSIBLY
FACE DEATH AND ARE VERY LIKELY
TO FACE DEATH.
>> TO FACE DEATH.
>> NO, FACE HEARINGS.
AND WHAT THEY WANT TO DO IS
BASICALLY, I THINK THE
GOVERNMENT IS AT THIS MOMENT
BASICALLY WILL DISAPPEAR THE
PERSON, HOLD THEM IN CAPTIVITY,
AND THEN THEY WILL BASE ON
POLITICAL DECISION DECIDE WHAT
TO DO WITH THEM.
>> SO DO YOU THINK ANYTHING
CHANGES HERE?
DOES THIS REMAIN JUST SOMETHING
ABOUT ZERO COVID, OR DOES IT
BECOME SOMETHING BIGGER AS OF
COURSE THE PROTESTER SELINA
SPOKE TO WANTS IT TO BE, OR WE
SPOKE TO ONE FROM LONDON WHOSE
FAMILY IS IN EASTERN CHINA WANTS
IT TO BE?
>> I THINK THIS IS THE MATCH
THAT LIGHTS THE FIRST FIRE.
I THINK THIS ONE -- PERSONALLY,
I DON'T THINK THIS WILL MORPH
INTO MUCH.
THE CRACKDOWN IS COMING FAST AND
SWIFT.
I THINK THE QUESTION IS WITH
THIS ENLIGHTENING TO THE YOUNG
GENERATION, WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
NEXT DOWN THE ROAD?
WILL THE NEXT ISSUE COME UP WILL
WE SEE THE SIMILAR TYPE OF
PROTEST?
WILL THIS LIGHT, THI